blood vessels high level of nerves and
everything but when the skull is
squeezing the optic nerve and the optic
art in the optic vein that macula dies
it's called macular degeneration and
doctors want to do surgery and they want
to give you new glasses and all that
kind of stuff and really you need to be
dealing with the skull okay and so then
of course
um when you have let's say problems with
how the pressure and kidneys your own
dialysis
well that's because the arteries are
blocked in the kidneys you're not
getting these proper circulation into
the little glomeruli which filter the
blood okay get the dirty stuff out of
the blood and put it into the urine so
you can pee it out all right and
um and then the veins of course
again bring the cleaned out blood from
the kidneys all the way back up to the
lungs and the and the heart and that's
that cycle
and so and then of course you have to
worry about what you eat your doctor has
made a mistake 100 years ago it's going
on maybe 200 years now okay uh
yeah I'd say it's a little over 100
years maybe 150 years doctors blame
plaque in the arteries because you can
see this in the microscope when you take
a you know make a slide out of an artery
that was plugged you can see that the
walls they already were thickened with a
fatty substance and they said ah this is
cholesterol
and he blamed cholesterol on plugging in
the artery so you got to stop eating
eggs stop eating animal fat and and take
these drugs we've come out with the
pharmaceutical industry came up with
um
these drugs to
um lower your blood cholesterol okay and
um it's one of those things where they
made a huge mistake okay they've killed
I'd say millions of people okay by
getting them off of
gluten okay they've killed millions of
people by getting off the gluten because
gluten makes it
so they killed millions of people
getting them off of cholesterol though
right thank you cholesterol thank you
thank you thank you thank you thank you
for correcting me yeah cholesterol yeah
they got everybody off of the
cholesterol
okay
um but um and they should have kept him
on more more
cholesterol and no gluten gluten was a
problem okay gluten of course was forced
on people when doctors would say you
know the reason why you're constipated
is you don't need enough grain you need
to eat more whole grain eat more whole
grain eat more whole grain eat more
Wheat by the round note see more we
brought around oats and to take a little
break have some Buckley pancakes and
buckwheat cereal for breakfast and
um
and so forth and of course all these
grains that wheat Brown ran oats have
gluten in them the Bad Guys gluten and
it causes all those Villa in your
intestines to go away the Villa the
little finger like projections and make
the lining of your intestine look like a
shag rug I'm gonna shag rug
um will I go away because you're eating
gluten okay
uh your your intestines look like a
plastic too if you lose 90 percent of
your absorptive surface and then you're
really in trouble
that you're really in trouble okay and
it's one of those things where you got
to pay attention here you must must eat
eggs and of course we have an I-26 it
says right on the label provides 25
percent of your day you know one dose
provides 25 percent of your daily
requirement of cholesterol oh my doctor
says I have to take my cholesterol
lowering drugs
okay no no you you don't want to take
cholesterol rolling drugs you want to
take the I-26 you want to eat three eggs
twice a day with soft yolks not hard
boiled not fried
and
um people with with plugged arteries we
take people who have really big trouble
um they have not urinated in 10 years
okay now they've they've been in trouble
for 25 years they've been on dialysis
maybe three days a week
um for say 10 15 years and then the last
10 years they've been on dialysis six
days a week because they haven't
urinated at all in the last 10 years we
get them going on a healthy Brandon hard
pack we get them going on the
um
and see here we get them going on the
Hillary and hard pack we get them on the
ultimate daily classic catalyst so three
of those twice a day all the three words
all the daily classic talents
um and that supports healthy blood flow
through blocked arteries uh supports
healthy blood pressure and suddenly now
after 10 years of not urinating they're
urinating and so they drop the dialysis
down from six days a week down to three
days a week
and then in two more weeks you're
totally off of dialysis and and they're
going back to normal because suddenly
now the the arteries and the and the
kidneys are working properly and
bringing the dirty blood through the
arteries into the kidneys the kidneys
are filtering it okay and then in the
glomeruli and then the filtered blood
comes back up to the heart and the lungs
through the veins okay that's how the
cycle works
and so this is not a mystery but it's
one of those sad sad sad things where
the medical profession has not
corrected this in over a hundred years
is pushing 200 years has not corrected
their mistake that they made many years
ago because they make so much money okay
under the circumstances of course the
pharmaceutical companies love
the cholesterol-ling drugs okay
um
this is where the pharmaceutical
companies really made it when the doctor
said you know you got to lower your
cholesterol and they came up with these
um cholesterol lowering drugs
and this is what Finance the entire
medical industry
okay and so the doctors didn't want to
say we don't know what's going on here
we just need to lower
you know we just need to lower
um your blood pressure we need to make
sure you're urinating we're going to
give you dialysis or we're going to give
you
um drugs to dilate your arteries and all
this kind of stuff
but it didn't solve the problem and the
problem keeps getting worse and worse
worse worse because I keep because
people kept eating
the bad stuff which was the fried foods
you know fried foods no of no fried fish
no Fried Chicken no fried potatoes no
fried
vegetables no stir-fried anything
nothing fried okay because when you eat
fried foods that the fat turns into
trans fats heterocyclic greens and
acrylamides which cause
major damage to the walls of your
arteries and that's what caused the
arteries to be plugged okay was was this
inflammation caused by eating the uh the
oils and the fried foods and people
continue today to pay the price people
who eat those Foods pay the price now if
you get rid of all those Foods or bad
foods you save a lot of money and you'll
actually make money okay by getting on
our programs because now you're saving a
lot of money by getting rid of all the
bad foods that are expensive
and you can use some of that money to
buy your youngevity products and get on
the right programs to support your
kidneys support your lungs support your
heart support your brain support your
liver support your lungs support your
muscles support your arteries support
your veins support your nerves support
your cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue disc between vertebrae
bones all your glands including you know
your sex glands and so forth your eyes
your ears it all that requires these
nutrients
dissing your heart beating
you know 50 to 70 times a minute
for a hundred years 24 7.
your heart needs some support it needs
blood flow you have to keep those little
coronary arteries open
okay and that's why we come up with the
products we have
okay with all that said I'm going to
turn it over to you Becca all right
thank you so much Dr Wallach now for
those of you who exercise and are out
doing physical of course your
heartbeat's going to be above 70. I know
whenever I'm doing my running Doctor
while again depending on which exercise
I do I get up to like 150 even so making
sure that I have my 90 essential
nutrients my essential fatty acids which
help keep I'm getting to that
keep my blood clean my ultimate daily
classic to keep that circulation flowing
and then especially because I'm working
out and I'm sweating I do the rebound
also like Dr Wallach is holding up and
yes I prefer the powders
um they do have less sugar and I they
have more nutrients in them
and it's easy just to take a couple
Scoops put it in my water and go I don't
have to worry about it shaking Dr
Wallach or when I try to open it it
explodes because I can't always open it
the day before and then have it to
travel so
with that being said Dr willick
um
you had mentioned you know the the blood
going out of the heart being oxygenated
and then as it goes through all the
veins and arteries and
um capillaries and then going back so
you've got the the outgoing and then you
have the return and the return has less
oxygen in it it's true if you have less
oxygen less nutrients less of everything
because your body's been sucking all the
goodies out okay along the trail okay
from the heart to wherever it's going to
the lungs and the hearts and the brain
and the liver and the kidneys and the
muscles and the bones
but the return blood
is low in everything is low in nutrients
and low in oxygen low in fluid so it's a
little thicker the venous blood is
thicker than arterial blood doesn't have
the oxygen levels doesn't have the food
levels
and so it's I mean you can tell just by
doing an analysis of a blood sample
whether it came from a vein or an artery
so with that being said Dr Wallach if
there isn't a lot of oxygen and there
isn't a lot of nutrients in the blood as
it's leaving the heart that's even less
coming back that's correct
that's why people die
well when you have more and more carbon
dioxide no food
you die your heart dies your your liver
dies your lungs die your brain dies
and that's something that you found in
some of your studies referring to the
kidneys that the kidneys were losing
circulation there was really nothing
wrong with the kidney itself other than
the blood wasn't flowing through it yeah
the arteries are plugged
and so we want to make another continue
to do kidney transplants but see there
again they were getting the wrong
information they were getting incomplete
information just like saying all the
arteries are plugged because people are
eating cholesterol no no no
well it does have to do with the bad
foods but it's also not getting the
nutrients that the body needs in order
to have function at its optimal best
right that's correct
go ahead you get an A plus that's
correct oh I'll take it I'll take it
well doctor well like we have a few
hands up with us and then we also have
people that are putting comments in the
YouTube chat for some reason I'm not
seeing Rumble today but let's go ahead
and answer some questions Dr Wallach
first let's go to Mike Mike go ahead and
unmute yourself if you would please
okay I'm muted I can hear you too how
are you today what can what can we do
for you
well I've been on um
um I have a large prostate and I've been
on uh medicine since 2015.
and just this month I had a problem
where
um I couldn't urinate so I'm in Florida
I'm at doctors in Maryland
he said you're going to have to go to
the emergency room and they put a
catheter in the next day I saw a
urologist down here they took the
catheter out the following day then I
was back in the emergency room the
following week so so far they've done a
cystostomy they've done a CAT scan and
they won't do a MRI until the 12th
um my doctor in Maryland
he's looked at everything he just thinks
it's enlarged and
so I'm calling just to I've listened to
you guys on the radio at night a lot of
times and I'm just trying to learn
okay well let's let's look at the
prostate okay
um it has many functions
and one of the things you have to
appreciate and let me ask you a question
before you had a blocked urinary system
how many times are you waking up at
night to urinate once three times five
times ten one once probably you know
unless something was weird you know
sometimes it'd be twice but usually just
once okay how many times you're in your
urinate during the day is it frequent
during the day yes yes 10 times during
the day you know like once every couple
of hours yes yes okay all right and so
um let's see here do you have any
tinnitus or ringing in your ears no okay
do you have any balance problems any uh
issues with that balancer no
okay uh let's see here I'm I'm do you
have anything going on with swallowing
voice changes uh lots of sense of taste
anything like that no okay do anything
going on with your fingers or toes
um well my fingers
um when I'm sleeping sometimes they'll
sort of fall asleep if I got them in the
wrong direction
on my toes not my toes but my fingers
okay uh do you have anything going on
um let's see here
you say your prostate is enlarged do
they determine this for the scan yeah
with the CAT scan well I've always had
one but you know at this time it's way
up there like okay yeah and it could be
just a simple deficiency okay the
nutrients causing that
um okay and so there's they don't seem
too concerned about wanting to get a
biopsy anything like that yes yes they
want to do a biopsy but they won't do it
until I get the MRI on Wednesday so I'm
not in Maryland I'm in Florida and I'm
with new new doctors that I um okay
they're from the Cleveland Clinic okay
well keep us informed on that but
basically
um you know you could have osteoporosis
in the skull squeezing the spinal cord
and the spinal cord is squeezing the
nerves
um during the day and the evening and
that's why you're urinating so much
during the day because your spinal cord
is being squeezed by the skull and the
skull is telling the excuse me your
spinal cord is telling your urinary
bladder to urinate during the day okay
because your position and so forth
vertical and so on
the women get the same problem this is
not only in men but women don't have a
prostate gland so you can't blame it on
the prostate gland you know you can have
and you have some white gray and silver
hair all right this is not due to aging
this is due to a nutritional deficiency
and the same nutritional efficiency can
cause problems with connective tissue in
the walls of arteries and veins and your
urinary tubes and and also in the tubes
inside the prostate gland and so forth
uh your hair color we can get your hair
color to come back in months okay that's
very easy okay you just have to take the
proper nutrients how much you weigh sir
a 197. okay
all right and no high blood pressure no
diabetes Well at one point they told me
I had diabetes but I corrected it On My
Own by changing my diet and riding my
bicycle and I checked my blood sugar
almost every day and it's between 85 and
90. good okay so I don't take any
medicine for diabetes okay good but I
take a blood pressure pill
because they you know he won't let me
off of it but sure okay I understand
okay so we need you to get rid of all
the bad food I want you to get my book
Dr Wally's cooking without the bad foods
or 300 pages of of
um safe recipes and also safe cooking
methods then I want you to get to two
healthy brain and heart packs per month
there's one per 100 pounds of body
weight you're close enough to 200 pounds
I only weigh 142 and I take two healthy
branded heart packs per month I take a
full dose of breakfast photos at dinner
time
and it has the core of the 90 essential
nutrients
and then by getting rid of the bad foods
you know the fried foods and the
processed meats and the oils and the
glutens and the wheat and oats and the
buckwheat and the sugar and the
carbonated drinks including carbonated
water you'll save enough money to pay
for the supplements so it won't be a
burden to buy the supplements because
you're gonna be saving a lot of money by
getting rid of the bad foods
and then I also want you in addition to
the two Health abandoned heart faction
month I want you to take two bottles a
month of our MSM so you can take three
of those at breakfast lunch or dinner
time they're going to support and
promote Mains repair cartilage ligaments
tendons connective tissue discs between
a vertebrae bone Ray phone itself
including
the um making of white blood cells in
your bone marrow and your red blood
cells and platelets and all that kind of
stuff the MSM will help you do that I
want you to take our collagen peptides
get two of the little canisters of
collagen peptides you can take a scoop
without their morning drinks whether
you're eating drink
um you should use our rebound or sports
drink it comes in the Sticks
36 in a box each stick has 100 nutrients
in it we do have the kind of the little
canisters which we showed you just a few
moments ago okay the cancer has 36
servings and there's a little scoop you
put one scoop of this powder into a
bottle of water and you get your 100
nutrients we do have the cans uh 12
ounce cans or 12 cams in a case but the
cans do have carbonation in them so I
like to pop the tops on two of them
every night before I go to bed put them
in the refrigerator so it'll be flat in
the morning all the bubbly is gone by
morning so I'll have one with breakfast
and one with the lunch uh never later
than two or three in the afternoon I
don't want to be staying up all night
but each of each serving of the
of the um
okay the rebound of the rebound thank
you so each serving of the rebound
has a hundred nutrients in it
okay and the how the brand heart pack
has 215 nutrients in it you'll know
you're absorbing when your hair color
starts coming back okay usually within
two or three weeks after you're starting
it if you've given up all the bad foods
and you're on good recipes and stay away
from the bad stuff so you can absorb the
good stuff
um your hair color will start going back
in two to three weeks usually takes
about
um anywhere from two to three months for
it to completely you know grow out
properly the same color it was when you
were a teenager we have people who are
bald like a bowling ball for 40 years
and and three months time they had all
their hair back at the hair color that
they were when they were 12. okay this
is very simple stuff okay and of course
the doctors are frustrated with this
because
once you know that you can prevent and
reverse all these problems with
nutrition
you don't need
drugs to deal with the symptoms
because the symptoms are gone when you
solve the problem the symptoms are gone
but the medical treatment tends to be
drugs that treat the symptoms as opposed
to getting rid of the problem
okay so we we come at this from two
different directions so you know keep in
touch with us just remember uh the book
goes into the history of going from wood
and coal to shield for thousands and
thousands and thousands of years of
electricity plants only need three
minerals we need 60
uh Hell's Kitchen tells you what's
happened to humanity since we went to
electricity
there's no ashes associated with in your
house with generating or using
electricity for heat and cooking and
that kind of stuff air conditioning okay
and so once we went to electricity and
we went to hydroelectric and damming up
all the rivers it was no more bottomland
suddenly now
we're in trouble and doctor said oh you
know this is all genetic stuff a lot of
immune stuff just eat well you get
everything you need and come to me and
I'll give you a drug deal relieve your
symptoms okay and so get that book
Hell's Kitchen get the book it's on your
head get the book The Revolution and the
information will add 25 to 50 health
careers your life you'll save enough
money by getting rid of all the bad
foods to pay for the supplements in fact
you'll actually be on the positives I've
actually saving money by getting rid of
all the bad foods
and um all the gasoline you spend on
your trips to the doctors and the
pharmacy and clinics and all that kind
of stuff
um
okay and so do keep in touch with us
now well will somebody get in touch with
me with all this did I read that
so Mike yes yeah so Mike um if you're
what you can do is you can go to YouTube
you can find a replay of this program
and be able to re-listen to it and write
it down if you are working with uh
youngevity associate already get back
with them in order to get your products
on their way to you okay
okay so I can go to YouTube and find
this recording yes you can find all the
recordings from our programming on our
critical Health News Channel on YouTube
or on rumble or on Facebook we are just
critical health
okay well I appreciate it thank you so
much
all right thank you so much Mike and Dr
Wallach let's just move right over to
MIMA Mima go ahead and unmute yourself
well that was my grandchildren my name's
Leah and uh they've named my phone as
Memo's phone so thank you very much I
enjoy watching the program I do have a
couple questions
um Epstein-Barr virus
I have that it's actively replicating in
my system and I wanted to know if
there's a way that I can
um like kill it and get it out of my
system or is it something that just goes
in remission
are you taking are you taking already
um I just got started with a health
coach and I'm hoping that I have some
products gonna be at my house when I get
home today okay yeah you're needing that
these essential nutrients to support
your immune system
put the gun to the virus's head and kill
it we have colloidal silver it's been
used for thousands and thousands and
thousands of years safely put a dropper
full under the left side of your tongue
and drop it on your right side or tongue
four times a day when you wake up in the
morning about 10 minutes before each
meal and you can even do it again before
bedtime I do that and I don't have a
problem I probably don't have a problem
because I've been doing this for I don't
know 20 years
okay
thank you may I ask you a couple
questions about uh livestock
livestock go for it a little bit
different is there a way to prevent pink
eye in cattle
yeah
cut their eyes out
okay Dr Wallach that is not a solution
if they're exposed to the bug they're
gonna get pink eye okay so it just
depends on you know if you're visiting
somebody's farm and they have pink eye
in their livestock you go home you hug
your dairy cow then you're gonna give
her pink eye okay it's one of those
things okay okay so it's not a mineral
deficiency or something that
is a virus
you can also have yes you can also have
you know some um vitamin A deficiencies
okay but if they're eating
hay which is green they have
beta-carotene in there they're going to
get plenty of vitamin A so that's that's
not the issue
okay
um my second livestock question is about
sheep
I'd like to know if there's a natural
way to prevent worms and parasites and
sheep since they get that so badly okay
well again it comes down to
um contamination on your shoes manure
from somebody else's Farm somebody
delivering hay to you and they've got
the manure in their feet and so forth
and so
what you need to do is have a
um uh one of these you know four inch
high
trays you know
um in front of your barns in front of
your house in front of your Gates going
out into the pastures and anybody
anybody coming and you're going to have
you know disinfectant in there okay and
people have to
stand in a half inch of that
um disinfectant for their boots and
their shoes and so forth for about one
minute you just can't step through it
okay no you got to step you got to be in
it for one minute and kill any parasites
and kill viruses and bacteria and fungus
and yeast
thank you very much you bet
it's cheaper than a veterinarian coming
out constantly
all right thank you so very much for
joining us today and Dr Wallach so I am
I'm a little bit familiar with cattle
and pink eye and taking the colloidal
silver that you recommended and putting
a little spray a fine Mist on the top of
that bottle instead of doing the
droppers then as you're out in the herd
which I know some herds are a little
more wild than others others they come
right up to me they let me pet them just
do Quicks little sprays in the eyes
whenever you're out there you're not
touching you're not doing any
cryptocross contamination you don't have
to get them to hold still while you do
the droppers but that little fine Mist
sprayer you can get close enough do it
quickly they don't even know and it does
amazing stuff on pink eye whether it's
in livestock or in humans Dr Wally
because I've used it
well there you go without fail
so yes uh colloidal silver folks you're
gonna have to drink quarts of it if
you're gonna if you want to turn blue
but for regular use like Dr Wallach
recommends even daily use just a dropper
on each side of the mouth couple times a
day you are not gonna turn blue and it
actually gives the body that extra
little boost to be able to work through
the things that we're exposed to yes and
we've been doing this you know all
through this pandemic and we see so many
people that come from all over the world
and they hug you and shake your hands
and who knows what airplanes they were
on with who had the bug and this and the
other and we've been blessed with our
team being very healthy all through this
because we use the colloidal silver
faithfully and like you say oh you're
gonna turn blue
well yeah
you're gonna have to eat a lot of
quarters
your silver quarters Dr well like it's
not just any quarter because now they've
got like copper fillings and all mixed
metals and
craziness well let's go ahead and go to
the next town that is up Dr wellick
actually I want a quick a quick little
question here
um in
our YouTube chat
so Corey says I have a bad ankle I'm on
blood thinners uh because of a blood
clot and Pulmonary embolism uh the ankle
was broken or is broken and it caused
damaged in the left leg
what Dr Wallach would you recommend for
somebody based on a hundred pounds who
has experienced blood clot pulmonary
embolism broken bones
and they're currently on a blood thinner
okay well at 100 pounds uh there's
either young person or you know a lady
usually excuse me
um he is six foot tall and he weighs 257
pounds
well there's a difference you're welcome
257 six foot tall
57 years old 200 pounds and six foot no
no no it's six foot tall
257 pounds I saw you I could muted
myself
thank you Ruth Ellen you're welcome okay
yeah and so
um they need a lot of nutrition when
you're 277 pounds 57 5'7
I don't know why I keep getting 77 okay
okay 257. all right now this person
needs to get rid of all the bad foods
they need to get a hold of that book
doctor always cooking on the bad foods
for 300 pages of safe recipes and safe
cooking methods absolutely none of the
bad foods no fried foods no processed
Meats no oils no glutens no Wheaton oats
no buckwheat no sugar no carbonated
drinks even the diet one's got to go and
and carbonated water needs to go
and 257 I would go I'm gonna have all
this stuff going on
um especially with um blood clots okay
it can cause stroke and that kind of
stuff
um then fractures there's a lot going on
in this person okay so they need to
um again the two healthy brain in heart
packs two bottles a month of the
ultimate daily
classic tablets for circulation take
three of those three times a day hold
the daily classic tablets again uh let's
see here I'm gonna have two valves a
month of the MSM so take three of those
three times a day three Bill cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue disc
between a vertebrae bone makes one
itself
and in the healthy brain and heart pack
that has three efas and three EFA pluses
now since I'm taking two doses a day of
everything okay I'm getting three efas
twice a day and three fa pluses twice a
day I weigh 142 and that will prevent
blood clots okay because blood clots are
a deficiency of of the essential fatty
acids very important here okay the
fractures okay we need to throw in the
extra ultimate
and see here we also throw in the um uh
collagen peptides uh scoop of that with
the morning drinks for the evening drink
it'll be two of the small canisters of
the collagen peptide powder and then
also the Osteo FX I would take an ounce
of that twice a day at 257 pounds to
take an ounce of the outro FX twice a
day
and I would get our
if they have a garden
okay I would get our blooming minerals
and use our blooming minerals in the
garden so that the vegetables that
they're growing will have more minerals
in it so everything they put in their
mouth should have more minerals okay
very important okay use our bloom in
minerals in our Gardens and around their
cherry trees and Survey Cherry Pie and
all that kind of stuff okay
and don't forget gluten-free pizza
um I have three Poached Eggs this
morning and a nice wedge of gluten-free
pizza okay with all these vegetables on
top of it along with
um yogurt and berries and
uh my all my supplements and everything
including my rebound and so forth it's
an amazing thing when you take all this
stuff I'm getting 100 nutrients
four to six times a day
depending on what's going on I'm taking
100 nutrients four to six times a day
and in a couple of months I'll be 84
years old and you know most people think
I'm in my 50s or early 60s when they
look at me they can't believe that I'm
84. okay this is this is simple stuff
but I've been taking the stuffs I've
been taking large doses of these
nutrients since I was nine years old
okay I was taking the same stuff they're
given to 200 pound 400 pound calves and
people say oh you're just eating Alfalfa
no I was eating the Alfalfa Palace or
enriched with vitamins and minerals
there's vitamins and minerals are in the
Alfalfa that I was getting the nutrients
from okay and so that was the important
thing and of course
um with that knowledge you know we're
able to we're able to get rid of on
things like um
uh you can see here oh cisiobrosis I'm
the guy that found the cause of engine
cure of cisiobrosis thought to be a
genetic birth defect I'm a guy working
with Jerry Lewis I'm the guy who found
the cause of engine cure much history
gave it to Jerry Lewis he took it to the
much Joseph Association they fired Jerry
Lewis summarily on let's see it was
September 4th 2011. they fired him put a
gag on him so he couldn't say anything
and canceled the
um his um Telethon the next day and his
Telethon over 46 years had raised
two point
six billion dollars
and they summarily terminated him
because he brought them the Cure well he
died a couple years later but he knew
in his heart we had been successful
because I had talked to him many many
times after they put the gag order on
him and but he couldn't say anything but
I could share stuff with him and I could
hear him smiling on the other end of the
phone because he knew we had found the
cause prevention cure of mushroom we
also found the cause and prevention of
sediment death syndrome doctors were
saying for years and years and years and
years and years and years that son of a
distance Romans caused my mother laying
on the babies and suffocating him
I had to get my attorney Jonathan eboard
and I we sued the FDA eight times in
federal court on that one subject
got these nutrients put in a baby form
it was Enfamil and Similac and the like
we prevailed in all areas we got the
nutrients put in the baby formulas and
within 90 days after that happened
those three diseases just disappeared
those three things just disappeared you
don't hear about those three things
anymore because we put the nutrients in
the baby formulas and so we're very
proud that we're responsible for that
it's amazing Dr Wallach what happens
whenever you give the body the
nourishment that it needs because we
weren't made from just
sugar
and bottled oils I mean we weren't made
from those things we've got to give the
body back the things that it was made
from the things that create healthy or
cells
and as long as we're doing it in
intentionally making sure that it's
going into the body being consistent on
it
there's a lot of things that we can do
in writing our own health Journeys Dr
Wallach yeah and of course again this
was recognized but my authorities in
various organizations and
um I I did get the
okay
the uh let's see here this is the from
the United States 2015 is the United
Nations okay
um to see uh let's see here I won the
award okay A Lifetime Achievement Award
for the United Nations they only give
out two or three of those every couple
of years or so they're very proud of
that and then in 2011 I actually got the
Cloud Schwartz award for discovering the
cost of engine cure of cisiobrosis
that's me with the Gerhard trouser
receiving that award okay
2011.
okay
yep you've done a lot Dr Wallach and
that's why we're here today is to be
able to provide information to others in
regards to the research that you have
done the research that you've been
acknowledged
or but not in the way that it's reaching
the masses at that time and that's what
we're doing today let's go ahead and go
to one more hand Dr Wallach before you
have to go yes and Ted go ahead and
unmute yourself if you would please
you're on live with Dr Wallach
hi hi Dr Walter we're an extreme
pleasure uh my honor to uh to talk with
you or have a chance to ask a question
the kind words how can we help you
so I'm I'm doing pretty well I'm I'm
taking the 90 Essentials for many months
now
um I uh still have a I'm struggling with
blood pressure a little bit and it can
Spike kind of high so I'm wondering uh
okay
I weigh about 200 pounds okay any other
issues back problems how many times do
we at night you wake up to urinate once
three times five times none two three
times two three times
in the ears
um I think I might a little buzzing once
in a while
okay what about anything like um
dizziness or balance problems you have
to use a water stain nope okay no blood
pressure no diabetes no I do have some
blood pressure okay one last question
um
and see here
do you ever have to
um
and see here
uh
um or I want to go here
um do you ever oh do you ever get sleepy
after a meal do you ever you know eat a
big mealy dinner time and you're sitting
there watching TV and you fall asleep
anything like that yeah no not sure okay
that's a reactive hypoglycemia your body
releases a lot of insulin not your blood
pressure down
oh excuse me your blood and sugar you
said you had a little blood pressure
issue
right yes okay so at um 200 pounds I
want you to take get rid of all the bad
foods no fried foods no processed Meats
no oils no gluten no wheat Brown oats no
sugar no carbonate or drinks you know
the dot ones got to go and no carbonated
water no bubbly water I do want you to
take two of the healthy Brandon hard
packs for months you know ramp up to a
little higher uh numbers of nutrients a
full roast everything twice a day
staying away from the bad foods you'll
save enough money to pay for the healthy
brain and hard pack two doses a day I
want you to get two bottles a month of
the ultimate daily classic tablets and
take three of those breakfast lunch and
dinner I also want you to take the
collagen peptides take a
um uh scoop of that with your morning
drinks for the evening drink why don't
you get two bottles a month of the
ultimate daily classic tablets three
words ultimate daily classic tablets and
um
take three breakfasts for your dinner
time if you're on medication for high
blood pressure don't cold turkey off of
that but as blood pressure comes down
you can slowly reduce medication based
on the numbers usually within two to six
weeks
um your blood pressure will be down to
the normal range I also want you to get
our sweeties get two pounds a month of
our sweetie so you can take three twice
a day and that will prevent you from
getting that hypoglycemia because I
don't want you to fall asleep when
you're driving okay you eat a big dinner
and you're driving you get drowsy you
that's that's why people cross the
center line and kill themselves kill
somebody else so when you have your
active half guys see me we need to get
that sweeties so we resolve that problem
okay
will do I did have a question give us a
call or a couple of weeks because your
blood pressure is going to be good your
reactive hypoglycemia is going to go
away uh that ringing in the ears is
going to go away okay and the you know
those additional things can I ask how
much does it matter dude to eliminate
gluten I've cut way back on my gluten
but it's really hard with you know my
wife does the cooking and she she's
still uh you know we still have some
gluten
um what if you only shoot yourself in
the head once instead of five times
once it's enough yeah once is enough and
so two meals a week of gluten instead of
you getting really serious problems
Within
a year or two it might take you three to
four years
okay
it's just going to be a little bit
slower but you know but you gotta get
you gotta be zero gluten is there a good
word if you say the word that's the
challenge to get the zero gluten I'll
work on it I understand I understand but
you got to sometimes you just leave it
on the plate and don't eat it
yeah
and yeah
see I'm making some rice yeah
I know I've heard you say eat like an
Asian right yeah you want to eat like an
Asian and that's why because
they they live okay in the United States
depending on Whose number you're looking
at our our life expectancy is 73 to 75.
you look at Japan they're 84. they
essentially live 10 years longer than we
do and then China is a great great study
uh they have two populations in the
north they live on wheat in the South
they live on rice
the ones in the South live to be 75 the
ones in the north live to be 71.
okay
so this is this is unimpeachable
information and so it's one of those
things where you really have to watch it
uh you will be blessed with a longer
healthier life spend more time with the
people you love
okay and I apologize for I keep looking
at the clock here I got two more minutes
and well now your time is up doc oh so
thank you thank you I've been given
strict orders to make sure that you are
not late for your next appointment so I
just want to thank you again for joining
us here Monday through Friday from 12 to
12 50 ish
on daily with Doc so thank you again Dr
Wallach you have a fabulous day and
happy Easter happy Good Friday to
everybody who
um takes the time to
consider the day and the events that
happened
um so many many years ago on the day not
so much this specific day but this is
the day that we kind of observe it in
the Christian faith so
puppy Easter everybody hope you all have
a wonderful wonderful weekend if I could
get my co-hosts up with me I just want
to give a special shout out to Ruth
Ellen Sanchez and Marilyn pazera
um the two of them were working extra
hard today as they were going through
and making sure that the information was
being shared in the chat monitoring our
YouTube and Facebook groups sharing
information to me so that if we got to
it
or we had time we could get to it but
folks if we did not get to your question
please use our website and contact us
option
um and send in your questions if you are
working with a youngevity associate
already or somebody referred you
specifically to this program please get
back with them and say thank you for
sharing this information with me how do
I myself get on the products that they
were talking about and if somebody
shared this program with you it's
possible that they may have their own
special way of ordering
if nobody has ever shared this
information with you you found it on
your own and you have never tried any of
the youngevity products we do have a
shopping cart in store we have a store
with a shopping cart on daily with
doc.com but again that's for people who
are not not currently working with
somebody
who are associated with youngevity now
Roselle and Sanchez she does like
extra Duty with me she keeps me in line
and I am so thankful for that
um all the things that she has learned
as I have stretched her
and taking her out of her comfort zone
um thank you Ruth Allen for being
you're welcome we appreciate that and
Marilyn also and the tech new technology
that she's learning and using her skills
that she has from her past careers and
life in making sure that the information
is being shared in the chat so she's
doing a fabulous job with that and
helping the people in I just greatly
appreciate my team even the ones that
aren't here I know that there's a couple
of them that are doing some marketing
for us
um without being here in the show but it
takes a team folks and if you have any
skills that you would like to utilize to
help promote
Wellness
not sick management but promote Wellness
promote healthier living promote being
able to build an additional stream of
income helping others there is nothing
wrong with being thanked for helping
others and sharing information with them
about things that they can do to be
empowered and take their health back
take their life back even financially
so we just want to make sure that you
know that there are opportunities
available
get back with the person that shared
this program with you or use our website
contact us and we'll be able to get you
in contact with a certified holistic
health coach
to help you figure out what it is
exactly that you want to do for yourself
or your community
we have a phone number with the call
team standing by at
855-949-3377 for those who have never
spoken to anybody about Dr Wallach or
the youngevity products at all and I do
want to throw in
Dr Wallach has many many Publications
and if you are interested in getting
some of his books make sure you go to
drjwalik.com he didn't mention it in the
show but I want to make sure that I
mention it because that's how he makes
his income he has completely turned over
the business of youngevity to to his son
and his wife and they're in control of
that he does not get a paycheck from
youngevity and he did that on purpose he
did not want people to say
well you're only pushing these products
because you make a buck off of them and
that is not true he does not get a
paycheck from youngevity so visit his
website
drjwalik.com and get
get a get a book start gaining knowledge
we even have some eBooks there some
digital books for those of you who use
CD players there's CDs there as well
that you can listen to previous messages
that Dr Wallach has made available that
have been impactful
very impactful in the lives of others
and I'm working on putting those CDs
into digital downloads as well
so thanks for listening to me Rambo my
name is Becca dukes and on behalf of
daily with doc.com have a wonderful
weekend and we will see you next week
Monday through Wednesday next week as we
are going to take some personal time off
12 to 12.50
Pacific time here on daily with Doc
zoom.com
bye for now
happy Easter everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign